[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with polly mckenzie
director of the demos think tank and pr
consultant alex dean they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages
a censored version of sue gray's report
into lockdown breaking parties at
downing street is due to be published
imminently that's on the front of the
eye
which has apparently left the senior
civil servant infuriated that's
according to the times
the mail says there is outrage over the
quote shambles which has left the
government in limbo for months
the financial times reports on claims of
a stitch up between the metropolitan
police and the people who are being
investigated
one mp has described the met as a broken
organization over the handling of the
investigation that's from the guardian
the prime minister is headed for a
showdown with his back benches according
to the express over the hike in national
insurance due to concerns about the cost
of living crisis
oil companies bp and shell are making
huge profits 900 pounds a second thanks
to the rising price of gas that's the
mirrors exclusive
while the telegraph finds that energy
bills are expected to rise by nearly a
half to almost 2 000 pounds from april
kiss me quick step the sun reports on
the latest strictly come dancing romance
and we're joined tonight by as i was
saying paulie mckenzie director of the
demos think tank and pr consultant alex
dean polly alex thank you so much for
joining us um
it seems there really is only one story
uh let's have a look at the eye and
polly do you want to bring us up to date
with where we are with the sugray report
well it's been you know a day of twists
and turns um there has been
discussions about when sue gray's report
will be published will it be censored
will the met police uh hold it back what
will they hold back
just incredibly complicated all day but
where we've got to at the end of the day
is we are now expecting the sugray
report next week as you're just
reporting
that any of the parties which the
metropolitan police is investigating
will only have a minimal reference in
but they will be redacted rather than
removed entirely which means there is
some hope that at some point that longer
version of sue grey's report may be
published the metropolitan police has
issued a statement saying that they are
not investigating any of the serious
offenses that people were sort of
suggesting around covering up evidence
or anything that might have gone to a
jury trial they're exclusively looking
at
uh possible uh breaches of the
regulations that would be dealt with by
a fixed penalty notice so once they've
reviewed sue gray's evidence they are
going to be
writing two possible perpetrators asking
them if they had a reasonable excuse and
if not issuing a fine
uh and then the matter will be closed so
that's basically where we've got to but
the controversy as the papers are
reporting are about whether
the way the met intervened really at
quite a late stage to say actually bits
of that report need to be removed
feels like it's contributing to kind of
cover-ups and delays
whether that was
absolutely the metropolitan police's
intent or not that's i think how it's
coming across in the papers uh this
evening
um interesting alice what do you make
let's have a look at the times because
they're saying that uh sugree has been
left
infuriated with what's going on
yes because of course she was
commissioned to do a report that as she
understood it would be made public in
its entirety and i think the case for it
becoming uh public uh wholesale in the
end is irresistible but there are
reasons for the metropolitan police to
ask um see gray not to mention things in
the course of her report now and those
reasons apply to both sides involved
both the police and those who are being
investigated for the police it is rare
to uh never happens that the police have
the entirety of their investigation or
their evidence rehearsed in the media
before they interview someone or put a
case to somebody who is suspected of an
offence so it's not in their interests
for that to happen
and on the other hand
what polly was saying about the
procedure is right for these um you know
fixed penalty only um offenses but
misdemeanors but on the other hand
somebody who gets one of these letters
might contest it might say it wasn't me
or say i'm innocent of that and that it
that could in the end lead to court
proceedings they could appeal uh the
suggestion that they should be the
recipient of a fixed penalty notice and
in the end it could
conceivably or feasibly prejudice those
proceedings that their name or their
case had been rehearsed in the media
before it was even put to them so for
those reasons i think the met is
actually a very unfashionable view i
know but i think the met is right to ask
sue gray not to publish those details at
this point
what about you potty do you think it's
reasonable
well it's interesting that alex who is
of course a barrister so you would
expect to be completely um okay with all
of these matters of law used the word
prejudice and the metropolitan police
used the word prejudice in the first
statement that they made today they then
briefed that perhaps they shouldn't have
used the word prejudice it's usually a
word that's used in relation to jury
trials where of course if lots of
information
has been in the papers about a potential
serious crime that might prejudice a
jury's ability to
genuinely uh examine the facts of the
case on their merits as presented in
court
if as alex is right that these fixed
penalty nurses could be contested they
would go to a magistrates court they are
summary offenses and so therefore the
that question of being prejudiced in
front of a jury
simply
doesn't amount here people did think at
the beginning of the day that it might
because perhaps sue gray had uncovered
evidence that uh for example uh evidence
had been deleted that phones had been
wiped that emails had been deleted in
order to to cover up um relatively minor
crimes uh you may remember chris hewn
who was a liberal democrat cabinet
minister was uh caught speeding um and
instead of just fessing up and losing
his license it was then discovered that
he'd got his wife to take those penalty
points that was then a very serious
crime uh which did go to um a
court um
led him to be
sent to prison and his wife as well so
you know it was possible it seemed at
the beginning of the day that something
like that might be transpiring where the
cover-up was much worse than the
potential offence but the metropolitan
police cleared that up and they said
that no they are only looking at
these uh breaches of the regulations
which could go at worst to a fixed
penalty notice and then if that's
challenged to a magistrate's court so i
i think it's it's kind of overkill from
the met and i think they also just
classic met unfortunately just haven't
thought about the court of public
opinion and the absolute essentialness
in a democracy a liberal democracy like
ours that the police are seen to be
independent of the executive that they
are not just in hock to ministers and
that they are able to hold even the
highest office holders in the land to
account if they break the law
interesting alex what do you think about
that term overkill do you think it is
overkill
it might be you have to forgive me uh
kimberly i had a little trouble hearing
some of what polly said but i think i
got the gist of it um i think that uh
it's i mean given that these were fixed
penalty notice offenses from two years
ago some people on the one hand would
regard it as overkill to investigate it
at all but plainly that wasn't going to
wash
because so many people were calling for
it it does amuse me now that some of the
government's most fervent critics who
demanded that it was invested the
government was investigated by the
police time and time again now say
because the metropolitan police's
investigation which they called for
might not suit the timetable they want
because of sue gray's report they say
it's terrible and they're furious with
the metropolitan police for doing
exactly what they called for so whether
it's overkill or not it's not really
down to me they'll have to decide um
whether that's right but yes is it right
to investigate like this um for
something that's a fixed penalty note
from two years ago i would probably
point to what polly was saying about
justice being seen to be done and us and
nobody being seen to be above the law it
is different if an offence is alleged to
have happened in 10 downing street to if
it happens um just to the man in the
street or committed by the man in the
street it's very important that those
who make our laws are involved in the
making of our laws are seen to be above
approach
okay um
just very briefly polly and we'll come
back to this after the break because we
do need to go to a break but just
quickly
the ft weekend who are they well who are
they is who is accusing the met of this
stitch up that you mentioned
um uh well lots of people including uh
quoted here sir davey who the leader of
the liberal democrats who um
he he measures his words a little he
said if if a perception of a stitch up
between the met leadership and number 10
will damage our politics for generations
and i think you know we
there's absolutely no evidence that
there has been a stitch up or a
conspiracy
but i think that the metropolitan police
having cressida gave a good statement
actually to to the the london assembly
earlier in the week where she talked
about um the importance of uh tackling
these offenses if they were you know
the most egregious offences and there
was little chance of a defense is that
that that question of how do you deal
with this is incredibly difficult it's
incredibly difficult of course to
prosecute or or take on the prime
minister of the land over the breach of
law in his own home that's always going
to be a challenge to the institutions of
the state and it doesn't at the moment
feel like those institutions have really
lived up to that challenge in ensuring
that all of the public can have
confidence that justice will be done
okay alex i see you shaking your head
we're gonna go to a break polly and alex
we'll be back in a moment we'll be back
in a moment thanks
um coming up energy bills are set to
rise by nearly half under new plans
here's a story in the telegraph
[Music]
hello again you're watching the press
preview with me now polly mckenzie the
director of the demos think tank and pr
consultant alex dean
thanks again for joining us let's talk
about energy and bring up the front of
the daily telegraph alex this is
terrifying that you could have to pay
1900 pounds from april for your energy
bills
and of course the number is a projection
and speculation but nobody is in doubt
that bills will go up a lot if nothing
changes in the current course of
circumstances with energy providers and
it is of course not helped by what is
happening between russia and ukraine
either not that we are massively
dependent on that region for our energy
per se but because there is a knock-on
effect in energy markets and you could
there's only so much to go around it is
i would say
part of the point that is behind those
who argue the uk should become more
energy sufficient because it will
insulate you no pun intended from the
shocks of events like that and from uh
the vicissitudes of being reliant on
foreign energy there is no better
example or time to argue for the uk
having more power supply of our own than
what we're seeing on our front pages
today
it's it's absolutely terrifying let's
have a look at the front of the mirror
and polly tell us what you think energy
firms are they're earning 900 pounds a
second this is bp and shell um according
to the mirror
yeah because there's two parts to most
of the energy companies they're
integrated vertically integrated so they
are doing the kind of wholesale supply
and the retailing and on the wholesale
side gas prices are so high that they
are making a lot of money and whilst
alex is right that this this figure this
estimate is a is only an estimate it's
based on basically a an average of
wholesale prices over six months up
until today and so we now kind of have
all of the numbers to plug into the
algorithm
it may be out by a few pounds but it's
basically this is what it's going to be
and it's not actually a cap on people's
bills either it's a cap on the amount
you can pay per unit than averaged out
to a normal house so if you are like uh
the energy user you had on on your show
just very recently who has high costs
because of uh equipment or because
you're at home all day if you're
disabled
your energy bills could be much higher
than this there is no question that the
government has to intervene in the short
term that has to be simply getting cash
to people to help pay their energy bills
if they're on low income or have high
costs and in the longer term it's a
combination of what alex talked about
plus insulating our homes and energy
efficiency you know we don't have the
highest energy prices in europe but we
basically have the highest energy bills
and that's because our homes are just so
rubbish
okay
polly and alex we'll leave it there for
this hour thank you so much